I describe impostor syndrome as having
three elements to it the first is the
belief that other people have an
inflated view of your own abilities or
skills are far more inflated view than
you have in yourself the second factor
is that you have this intense fear that
you'll be found out and exposed as a
fake and the third element is that you
constantly attribute your success you do
recognize to other factors outside of
your own abilities or talent when plas
syndrome can feel like a dissonance or a
disconnect but if you have it a lot and
you're constantly feeling that way then
the disconnect between what you see as
yourself and your public view just grows
bigger and you feel fake and you're
feeling impostor my imposter syndrome is
something that affects so many of us
that actually to call it a syndrome is
probably a little bit inaccurate because
that suggests it's kind of mental health
condition or there's something wrong
with us but you know when it's 70
percent of us it's probably more likely
to be something that is almost normal
really you can't have impostor syndrome
without being successful you've got
people like Tom Hanks who you'd think
well they've made it they must be
confident in their abilities no matter
who we are no matter what we've done
there comes a point where you think how
did I get here and am I going to be able
to continue this when are they going to
discover that I am in fact a fraud and
take everything away from me
I think a little bit of self-doubt is
very good for self development the
imposter syndrome people are the ones
double-checking their work working
really hard trying to get everything
right never satisfied always looking for
more training opportunities for more
learning opportunities and those are all
potentially good things there are a
number of factors from childhood that
may contribute to impostor syndrome when
children are put on a pedestal that's a
very very difficult premise to look to
live up to and that can help make you
feel an imposter because if you're not
perfect then you're not the golden child
that they think you are
the term imposter syndrome was first
coined in 90
in 78 by Pauline Clanton Susanne
Eames in a paper that they entitled
imposter phenomenon in high achieving
women so it was originally something
that was thought to only affect women
when we talk about imposter syndrome in
the workplace I see that as the same for
men and women but I do see a lot of men
who don't think their mannina social
media has a huge role to play in
impostor syndrome we can see everybody
else's successful lives the more we
present our best self to the world the
more other people will develop impostor
syndrome because they're never going to
measure up I've had people who wanted to
give up their jobs their high-flying
jobs because they fear so much being
found out that they'd rather give it up
and handing their notice even though
objectively that they're not fake and
objectively they are successful if you
think that you are suffering from
impostor syndrome actually look
objectively at your successes write down
the things that you are successful at
and then look at all the reasons why you
might have achieved that success assign
a percentage scores to how much you
think that factor contributed to that
achievement you can mistakenly attribute
all of it to work but when you put it
down on paper you'll realize how
ridiculous that is so it's a bit of a
reality check and it makes you stop and
acknowledge your successes Impostors
feel that they can't accept anything
that's less than perfect learn to make
mistakes and to accept failure you don't
have to be brilliant all the time that
you can be good enough
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon